so I was asked to talk about what two
libraries bring to the table to enable
researchers success in this changing
environment first I'll talk about what
inherent and professional skills and
knowledge do we have to support the
transition and enable researcher success
second I'll talk about what systems and
services are already in place that can
help institutions and researchers
respond to the requirements and third
I'll talk about what can and will
libraries do next to help ensure
research or awareness and support
changes necessary in research or
workflow to ensure compliance so what do
we as librarians bring to the table by
virtue of our skills and knowledge first
librarians are skilled at bringing order
and making very complex information out
of information accessible and the funder
mandates are as a whole very complex
next through our subject liaison and by
subjects liaisons I mean librarians who
have library and subject expertise and
are assigned to work with specific
departments and colleges and do
instruction work these subject liaisons
are strong supporters already of the
research process for students and
faculty this means we create guides for
finding very specific types of
information and we train scholars to
navigate complex information systems at
research institutions were often fully
embedded in departments and colleges
finally we are collaborators and
generalists by nature meaning that we
are already connecting parts of our
institutions together by virtue of our
central place in the structure of the
university if we take a few steps back
and think about this event it was a
library that brought us all here today
to talk about the issues facing us this
is no surprise to me academic libraries
are often considered to be the heart of
the institution
because of our support of nature are
wide reach our responsibility to all
facets of the University to students
faculty researchers and staff we are
well poised to provide support
throughout the scholarly communication
process including helping researchers
with tools and information they need to
comply with funder mandates libraries
have the relationships to outreach and
presentation skills the collaborative
mandate to bring researchers and various
parts of the institution together to
discuss and plan to solve the complex
issues we face so moving on secondly
amps talk about what ways have
librarians already created support
systems that can translate directly into
this changed environment in recent years
librarians have laid the groundwork for
a lot of the support mechanisms that we
already have in place to enable
researcher success librarians were early
and outspoken advocates for open and
public access to academic and scholarly
communication because of what librarians
call the serials crisis we were by
necessity early advocates for those who
are wondering what the serials crisis
was and is let me digress for a few
moments since the early 1990s a number
of things converged to create what
academic and research libraries call the
serials crisis these things include the
proliferation of new academic journal
titles a push from major academic
publishers to buy journals from learned
societies significantly increase
subscription costs for libraries and
over time the transfer of academic
journals from print to electronic
versions which gave the publishers the
opportunity to licensed access and not
sell content which in turn put the
sharing of academic information under
contract law instead of copyright law
briefly I'll describe the consequences
of these events in concrete terms first
more journals meant libraries needed to
subscribe to more titles
second for-profit ownership of journals
meant cost could and did increase to
astronomical heights an increase of
especially in some fields more than four
hundred percent over a 20-year period
third under contract law where libraries
pay for access to digital information
versus owning the print libraries are
constrained in how they can share
academic information interlibrary loan
can be affected permission is now needed
for some classroom use of academic
materials and faculty have had to ask
publishers for permission to use their
own work in teaching and research or
even to share it with other scholars on
their websites publishers have recently
begun sending scholars takedown notices
to remove their own articles from their
online scholarly profiles and webpages
fourth for-profit publishers created new
ways of selling academic information to
libraries one of the most used is called
bundling which allows them to write
contracts at a span a period of time
often three to five years and be include
predetermined annual percentage
increases see do not allow for changes
or title cancellations which takes away
the flexibility in often unstable
library budgets this in turn often leads
libraries to commit to spending the
majority of their budgets on academic
journals mostly in STEM fields which
leaves book purchasing mainly in the
humanities and some social sciences to
fall by the wayside because of the
contracts with large journal publishes
publishers and finally in the US the
serials crisis affected public
universities more deeply and earlier
than private ones however private
institutions are now responding to the
serials crisis and having their own
budgetary issues globally particularly
in developing nations the effect is
drastic for example at the University of
Mexico one of Mexico's top schools the
situation is so dire that the university
can only subscribe to one print not
elect
on a copy of the journal nature for the
entire university they can't afford the
electronic subscription service thus the
serials crisis is a global problem for
the advancement of knowledge so to get
back to what libraries have already done
in the mid to late 1990s libraries
brought the conversation about open
access to their individual campuses
through forums and events for faculty
and researchers to discuss the issues
libraries pulled together all the
players to analyze the challenges we
were facing and supported a wide variety
of collaborations to propose and test
possible solutions on a national level
library supported the creation of groups
like spark spark which is the scholarly
publishing an academic resources
coalition was founded in 1998 and it is
now an international alliance of nearly
800 academic and research libraries
working to create a more open system of
scala communication more recently as an
referred to librarians formed kopi or
the coalition of open access policy
institutions its members our librarians
and library administrators who work at
institutions that have an open access
policy or that are actively working on
one activism and federal lobbying by
these groups and others in large part
led to the passing of FERPA the
introduction of faster in the House and
the Senate and in the same month but
faster was introduced februari 2013 the
White House issued the directive that we
are responding to today that directive
required federal agencies with over a
hundred million in annual conduct of
research and development expenditures to
develop a plan as we already heard to
make peer-reviewed publications publicly
accessible to search retrieve and
analyze so our support for researchers
is a natural and desired outcome of our
support for the directive in the first
place it's just the sort of action with
teeth we've been pushing for from the
federal government and which we are
poised to
port librarians have also created some
specific tools and support that are
already in place first through the
creation of research data management
programs and tools librarians have done
a lot to support researchers and making
their data open access specifically in
the area of creating data management
plans for example in January two
thousand eleven eight institutions five
of them academic libraries contributed
personnel and development to create
what's called the DMP tool or data
management plan tool this tool can be
customized for individual institutions
and is a free service that helps
researchers and institutions create
high-quality data management plans that
meet funder requirements next many
institutions have passed open access
policies and have built or are in the
process of building open access
repositories for a variety of types of
scholarly output most often articles and
conference papers but in some cases data
these institutions have been exploring
workflow management tools that can
include funding information and can be
used by researchers to track their
articles and data and help ensure they
are compliant through groups like kopi
and spark best practices for processes
repository design and outreach can be
easily shared and built on at a wide
variety of institutions and while spark
requires a paid membership much of its
output is freely available and
membership in kopi is free as long as
institution to meet the requirement of
having or working on an open access
policy as a member of the steering
committee of kopi and it's past chair I
can tell you that as soon as that AAU
memo came out that prompted the flurry
of concern on many of our campuses
coping members were sharing emails with
each other on how different campuses
were talking about supporting compliance
so now we turn to the future and the
third piece of what I wanted to talk
about what specifically can libraries do
next
knowing that we have a lot we can use
already and build on to get us there
first librarians can help decipher the
individual Thunder mandates and create
guides for individual disciplines and
funding requirements for how to comply
for both articles and data my hunch is
that many librarians are working on
these guides already and through some
excellent early work from spark we have
a clear though complex amount of
information to pull from and a lot of
this is available on a spark website
second as we've already been doing for
open access in general we can use our
librarians who our subject liaisons and
who are doing outreach and training to
raise awareness of and teach researchers
how to comply with requirements we can
hold workshops and training sessions for
faculty researchers grad students and
postdocs and everyone involved in the
process on how to manage their own data
and they're published works so that
version control is possible third
through our central role on campus we
can continue to initiate and/or support
collaborative efforts to bring all the
necessary groups and departments
together to find solutions these can be
sponsored program offices research
offices data management support
institutional repositories departmental
administrative support and specifically
grant administrative support compliance
and ethics legal offices especially
copyright and IP experts data security
Provost level representatives and above
IT solutions and many others with the
shared goal of making things easier for
faculty and researchers we will work
together with campus partners to design
and create tools and workflows that
insert their compliance into the
research processes through events such
as this one and other marketing and
outreach efforts we can raise awareness
about why and how to be compliant and
finally we can continue to advocate for
passing open access policies at
institutions or an individual colleges
that do not yet
have one with these mandates there is an
opportunity to expand the conversation
to talk about open and public access
beyond just that affected by the
mandates this then can help create
campus-wide support systems that will
include open access and public access as
part of an institutional support system
thanks
[Applause]